the prospect of returning to yet another
lockdown poses
us all a challenging start to the new
year but my next guest
might have some useful tips on how to
look after your mental well-being during
these
unprecedented times uh joining us now
the psychotherapist
lucy beresford and the amy dr alex
george himself has recently started a
campaign calling on boris johnson to
meet with him to discuss
improving mental health education in
schools guys
lovely to have you on the program this
morning okay brass tacks
we're all feeling a bit grim this
morning i don't know about you but i can
speak personally that you know you wake
up this morning knowing you're gonna
have to come in and read this news out
hour
after hour after hour and it doesn't
exactly fill me with joy i mean lucy to
you first
i suppose the starting point in all of
this is to say to people you know
don't worry you know plenty of people
will be feeling exactly the same as you
this morning
that's very true and it does help to
know that
you're not alone that other people are
perhaps
struggling and that if you could reach
out to them or they reach out to you
that can be very supportive
but the problem is we've already had two
lockdowns we know what they're like
the study from the university of
cambridge came out only recently which
talked about
how negative the impact on the mental
health of our young people in particular
the effect of lockdown one was and now
we're in lockdown three
so our anxiety is partly about how to
get through
the current predicament but it's also
about knowing that it has
this really long legacy
of affecting and actually damaging our
mental health and i think the campaign
that dr alex
is trying to initiate with boris is
absolutely spot on
because we all need to pay attention to
our mental health but we adults have
quite a lot more resources
available to us to take care of our
mental health
our younger people let's say people
under the age of about 22
they have fewer resources they can't
necessarily
implement so many uh activities
in order to protect their mental health
so we have to do that for them
alex then an appropriate moment for you
to tell us
a bit more about your campaign whether
or not mr johnson has answered the phone
call yet and
and organized the meeting but but also
tell us just a little bit you know you
are someone who has worked on the front
line
during this pandemic you yourself must
have had to come up with some
coping mechanisms absolutely good
morning neil good morning lucian
first thank you lucy so much for your
support i think it's been very important
to me to have
um experts such as yourself actually
saying alex what you're doing is right
and
we do want change i think that's what
i've seen over the last few months
ever since my brother passed away i've
been speaking you know behind the scenes
really to
mental health organizations some of the
biggest ones in this country
and educational leads teachers parents
students schools to find out more
information about what's really going on
and what we can change i think
there's been a unanimous agreement that
there needs to be change there isn't
enough support at schools
there's not enough education at an early
enough age to
prepare children properly for the
challenge we face and ultimately just as
lucy said there
what this pandemic is going to do to the
mental health of young people is quite
honestly frightening suicide rates are
on the rise
mental health diagnosis are increasing
and it scares me
i think it scares everyone and i think
everyone's ready for
for change so that's why i started this
campaign i really want to speak to
to the prime minister uh and his team
um i have here had initial discussions
with um
some of some of his team and i'm very
hopeful that we can arrange a meeting
and that we can
start making change because this needs
to happen we're all ready for it to
happen so let's do it now before
before things get even worse than they
already are i mean
lucy again not nodding along as you were
commenting there alex i mean it's
now is that is the key word in all of
that isn't it lucy is making sure
is starting the preparations now for
whatever lies down the road and indeed
making sure that young people are aware
of the assistance that might be
available to them
yes two things to say about that one
we've got a golden opportunity
to all of us start protecting our mental
health going forward
this isn't just about the pandemic this
isn't just about
a sticking plaster for the next few
weeks or months this is about
instituting some really important
changes
in schools in education in hospitals and
in the wider society to make sure that
our mental health
is protected going forward beyond the
pandemic when coveted is no more
but absolutely right we need to
reinforce the message
to our young people that there are
places where they can go people that
they can talk to particularly young
minds
is a fantastic website they've got
brilliant helplines
so if you are struggling that's where
you can actually go and reach out and
get some support
so don't be afraid to ask for help
certainly in schools we need to
introduce mental health into the
curriculum asap
particularly now we know that schools
are going to be closing and exams are
going to be cancelled that's going to
really affect
the the well-being of our young people
and they need to know that they've got
some support
but also staying active staying
proactive the way to get through a very
difficult situation like this
is to recognize what you can't change
and recognize what you can change
there is a lot about this that we are
not in control of grown-ups as well as
youngsters
but we if we can focus on the things
that we can change
which are things like sleep protocol
what we eat
how much exercise we're taking how much
we're interacting with other people
how much we're doing for other people
kind gestures for other people
make them feel great but also make you
feel good how much
nature we're immersing ourselves in and
i speak as someone who's based in
central london but there is quite a lot
of nature that you can bring
to you spotting different leaves having
window boxes on your window
so that birds can come to your window
even if you don't have a garden
lots of resources lots of tips to make
sure that every single day you've got
some structure
you've got some self-care and you've got
people to talk to
and i just want to get a final word but
there's so much information in there
lucy that we will retweet a little bit
later on for people to get some ideas
but
but but alex the final word from you i
mean 2020 was
was clearly for many many people an
awful year for you more horrible than
for most i would i would suspect
how have you managed to to to hold on to
the positivity that you've been able to
express
to our viewers this morning it's been
it's been very hard it's been tough and
i think sometimes
um you just don't expect the situations
you find yourself in life there's a
there's a quote that actually got me
through what happened to my brother and
there was a life process into the deep
end you know at times
with family and friends uh we can
overcome seemingly
the most insurmountable challenges and i
believe that to be true we
we get through it together ultimately
and we find a way
i've really kind of incorporated some of
the tips that lucy talked about there i
i also live in central london but i make
sure i get outside and walk every day i
try and get some natural light
i try and be around green spaces even if
i had a busy day i do
20 30 minutes of exercise every day and
it really helps and those little things
add up to make a big difference and
and what i would say very importantly
for children you know like lucy who's
saying they can't necessarily
do these things themselves we need to
put them in place for them help them
support them what we're going to see the
fallout we're going to see
after this pandemic is going to be huge
especially with what's just happened
yesterday closing
the schools it's going to get bigger
let's not ignore it let's make let's
make change so
please boris johnson your team can we
meet and discuss some of the changes
that we can make some things we can do
that will make a difference
um and just alex just very very briefly
because we are about to run out of time
what what needs to happen in schools and
at what age
okay so i mean there's quite a few steps
i'd like to make but it needs to
incorporate all children we need to be
going from
years three and four years old all the
way up to 18. we need to be
integrating a really um quality
curriculum around mental health you know
teaching children about thoughts and
feelings as they grow up
or how to look after themselves what to
do when things go wrong
we also need to teach teachers better
around mental health to support them
because a lot of
the things i've heard from teachers are
saying but we've been asked to teach it
but we haven't been
taught we haven't been given the
information we haven't been supported
ourselves we need to support the
teachers to do the job
that they want to do and we also need to
provide support in all schools i believe
all schools should have a full-time
counsellor
it will help with children you know
staying in school if they're struggling
they can reach out for support there and
have immediate support at hand
so those are just some of the things i
want to change and those are things we
can do it can be done
it has been done in some schools we need
to make it nationwide and it will make a
difference i'm sure
well the one bit of advice that i will
provide and it's entirely inspired by
the chess set over your right shoulder
there alex a game of correspondence
chess
there are plenty of people around the
world wanting to to play with you
they're all out there waiting
alex george lucy beresford wishing you
both uh
very very well and thanks for joining us
on the program this morning andrew neil
thank you